This is Sade and this is Linah, two young servals.
These slender, medium-size cats are native to sub-Saharan Africa,...
...and have a gorgeous golden coat with black spots.
Servals have the longest legs of any cat relative to body size.
Their ears are also impressively large, and can rotate 180 degrees,...
...giving them a keen sense of hearing,...
...which helps them locate prey efficiently.
They're long, lean and can jump up to nine feet in the air,...
...to catch unsuspecting birds flying by.
Beyond birds, they mostly feed on rodents, insects and reptiles.
Servals prefer wetlands and areas with tall grasses near water.
Unfortunately, degradation of these wetlands is leaving them with less and less space,...
...while hunting for their prized coat remains a big concern.
This is the serval.